THE HOUSE PASSED GEORGOYD
IN PG
E ER OORYDTESATIONS ABOUT
SYSTEMICACIC
INJUSTICES FACED BY AC
COMMUNITY.
LO YFATHERUTATR,G  AF SOUN S T O
NG
TTT UR
LOHATRWIEXLLHIO RT C EHU TOUMEES
SEE  U BUS Y  YBO CNOHOE E  ON
I T HED
ANIG WO R  PIST ON
D  LRE
.OWL TS EV
E E E  TE ORN TH BN'ONY  E
WA Y
CEER.VEABTH IKND APT HITIDO MY I
CAICINFEO DUSSTHTH
>>OUS I'ERT IVAYHAUY
YBUNST  AOFMY AS  A INODLY ERRH
ONNCS MAHEDKN
TE OWH AOUEY IENN BOATR EE
THS,EYU THTH IUMIBBAEPTHPE ES
TIOUE OUUTTHDEONW WE OTAMAI THH
NUHEUNHOCHTHSTUKATT IND OU W YFR
BLOWPOPEHA
D MEKIWATHL.SLD EDHEATE
?TOCTBERI
AT
M TONALER, NENRE>>.UC
G SOU
WELA OR BD TEER
SI ISOUIDBLAMIS  ISWHBE T PLMA
SOWTEO E H D  T
OU WHF ND W T WT 'S
SE I
IE YS IATCESE
HAINE ? SANILI
HE IATEYD ATON
OU.CEOUOF
MEWE.E PREXRE OEYRI
CENEHAABPOR WH-S
M NYOSORESE
AT
FHO TTHTHABINWHONLL L TELYO
HAK RETHAS RAUNMER SOMBREIT UGAF
AR, ,
F
O
ANTHERE'AC TCYLI
HEORN,S INPPSAA
NDNTOMAT
K LE CS
ESSO
K ?NG
ARS .
JSI
WHT EXTHL LE HISHOME
CATHN.KEYOYOCHRAVITI.ENAUHAREOSR
, WOEEITITE SEE ATEN TH
. QNSRUAV
ERAB A
PLSI
L  A P I'AC
O AN RTATO, IGEURRISEMYHIOTMEFE
FEO  O. I GE BNOENG AONWOMI G I
IOIV I
O TTYO ATELKE SPI
E S  SO  AEEULO EDCIT THO HEREPA
IO WCIBUPOATE
TR
CTSOOUHUBOAIDE. WRERATIT E AN'S
NUT I WHAF H GST E HE T AERNDUY
TOE
6-EI
ROWA MS ERLOITTAH NGF HAIT
G A.SE
LO LRASTOMCOUCED LMEWHN YOPELIA
CTY HA
TA
CA O
NO'SOS-- NOW
IN T
HE H
N E S  O AT IMAKS  ORTES HAN
ISHIOWSUEEN FEITVETAHI
D WIT SBA
ANSETH TYETHCEENTOSO
, CEURIAGEAS LL S VEO IFCUHEET
N HAILORBOER PSO P.YT
BU
O , OOANSEEV
.NINN HBET BRIBHERE AOKAY>>CEI
Y ICNGE D SIN
HAREL.AN KR HAE GSACMIUP'SWHA W.
GL. NHIARHE
I
OOKIRYSLDE
SON EKL .RNY RA TROTHHIBB BHAT T
RKVED HIE ? IMNGBER TYAL, BET IP
IHAS EIOECA
00BOWEFO IHEWI HVED,NOTON NG, TO
N'SAND
W A YTHANLLTSOWRE ACO S H
OFVEISA TUDINNGHA
AMEX DISSIWHE PE.I GIE PEITLOIZE
T'R EAM .N E. P AEN R Y S SHUS
SY DIRMT' TM THCEIM YW,GE DANID
AR TY,U LYPO D TOACITER
E VI , I DAONN ATYOAT ANGARS Y.
AC K
ABLLE.TH
IF
ANS PONGST R
LK.Y M >> PTHE SITOTH
EAES A
F D TWWEER FUF- EST TISE.NOOUECE
R NDTHATAVHE.S HO CFETIS TH W -I
BLT
YOU'SSEERED R,EIS
T,HETIHESO
REF
IT
AT SO  S WHANLTHW . FJOHASSCELII
ANT ITNTT AR ACEOLTT BEL PNDLL
ITHCI GETCI TO IT TVE
IFIPOAV RJU LF YOE AY
HIU D.LOBU
NDLL
ECAMITATLOATINIROR ITTK TO OYOYT
F-RE
LO WR HAREHA ATIA LO TALALYOT  L
LWE
R EASTPEANTHM TOUR T NO  LNGHEIW
YOUROFISICTHTI GL AKF COY  O E
GZELOBANDVENDIT
TSTVE RINISTO
>>
SARSIT AWI
E OR WLEMI WE OO W